and uh uh
kristen is actually an md phd student
uh in our department in the biomedical
informatics graduate program where she's
getting her phd
and then we'll be returning to finish
medical school
today she's defending her dissertation
as part of her
degree in bioinformatics and
computational biomedicine
she received her bachelor's degree in
molecular and cell biology with a minor
in english from the university of
california berkeley before enrolling at
ohsu she conducted health policy
research in washington d.c on the health
security act of
1993 as well as pharmacogenomics
research at children's hospital oakland
on drug target discovery for
cardiovascular disease
her current research is supported by our
national library medicine
training grant and also the
ohsu medical sciences training program
grant
and her work explores the biological
relationship between obesity
and substance use disorders in humans so
in our department our approach for
um actually both phd dissertations and
and master's theses um uh
defense is that the uh candidate makes a
public presentation
uh after which questions can be asked um
and then um the uh public audience is
uh dismissed and uh leaving behind
her examination committee and herself
uh who may ask additional questions then
she's excused from the examination
committee and then they make a
determination
whether or not she has successfully
defended her
thesis so without further ado
i will turn the floor over to kristin
thank you so much bill okay hello
everyone
uh and thank you for coming today um i'm
gonna talk about the work i have done
for my dissertation project
which is titled a robot genetic risk
score
for predicting obesity and substance
addiction
before i begin discussing my own
scientific contributions
however i want to first give you some
context
as to why almost three years ago now i
chose this particular project to work on
for my phd
my hope is that after my talk today
you'll walk away with
two things the first a more discerning
lens through which to view
studies on precision medicine in the
setting of common complex diseases
and two a much deeper appreciation for
both the biological
and social complexity of addressing
conditions like obesity and substance
use disorders
in real patients
so to start us off why did i choose this
product
so estimating and then effectively and
compassionately compute
communicating disease risk to my
patients is at the core of what being a
physician
scientist means to me and it has driven
much of the work that i will present to
you here today
so despite the numerous risk factors
that i will eventually learn to
synthesize
evaluating patients
polygenic risk is not currently one of
these risk factors
for now polygenic risk which is defined
as the risk for disease or condition
based on many genetic variants
altogether has not made its way into the
clinic as part of standard of care
at least not directly however
risk function in general is central to
clinical decision making
especially when considering the
prevention of common
adult onset conditions like coronary
artery disease
type 2 diabetes and breast cancer and
while great
strides have been made within the
research community to understand
how exactly our genes contribute
probabilistically to disease
susceptibility
there is currently no clear consensus
how to combine clinical risk factors and
polygenic risks
inside the walls of an exam room
so for instance let's say a patient has
high cholesterol
smokes or has high blood pressure
if the patient's polygenic risk is in
the 80th
90th or 9th percentile seen here
in the top of the middle panel shaded in
dark blue
do we simply add that polygenic risk
to our clinical risk evaluation toolbox
to get
that particular patient's total or
combined risk
there are no easy answers but it's
becoming increasingly clear
that ignoring or assuming
we can rely on proxies or surrogates
like family history is probably not
going to suffice
most especially for those patients who
for one reason or another
do not have a family history readily
available and i want to take a moment
here
to pause and expand on this point when i
proposed this project
back in 2018 i cited adoption as one of
the
possible reasons why i as a future
clinician
would not be able to adequately evaluate
my patient's disease risk
but this is far from the only reason
and considering the current climate it
needs to be stated that the reasons
underlying water patients do not have
access to the health and medical
histories of their ancestors
are not all accidental they are often
the direct consequence of an erasure by
human on human violence
slavery and genocide and while we will
never recoup the full health histories
of these people
they have left breadcrumbs of biological
information
within the genes of their descendants
information that has the potential to be
recaptured and used
to benefit future patients of mine
so why do i and others
believe that the time has finally come
to think about how best to incorporate
polygenic tests into the clinic
so back in 2018 thanks to numerous
advancements
in biomedical data collection storage
sharing and analysis researchers were
finally able to generate polygenic risk
scores
for a handful of common diseases that
could identify individuals with risk
comparable
comparable to monogenic or single gene
mutations
so on the left i'm going to show you the
results from a 2016 study
to give you a sense of how monogenic
mutations
confer risk in a general population
this figure shows
the odds that an individual sampled
randomly from a general population
will have coronary artery disease these
odds are broken down by the presence of
a mutation in genes that we know
cause an inherited form of coronary
artery disease specifically
familial hypercholesterolemia
i hope you can see that the odds are
about threefold that an individual with
one of these gene mutations
will have coronary arteries compared to
controls
and that approximately one out of 222
people
have one of these mutations
now let's move to the figure on the
right here we are looking
at the distribution of individuals in a
general population
by their polygenic risk score for
coronary artery disease
which is plotted along the x-axis
here you can see that everyone to the
right
of this vertical light blue line also
has a brief
risk of coronary artery disease yeah
what i hope you can appreciate
is that instead of one out of 222 people
a whopping one out of 12 or rather eight
percent of the population has threefold
risk
this is a substantially greater
proportion of the population that has
risk comparable to
a known inherited artery disease
that has a patient today would currently
go
uninformed regarding their increased
risk
there are two major reasons why
accurately identifying these patients
going forward is so crucial
both of which i hope follows somewhat
intuitively
the first is risk stratified prevention
or appropriately targeting prevention
efforts
those patients with increased polygenic
risk for disease
the second reason is that many of our
drugs are intended to target
specific medicine action and by
pinpointing patients whose polygenic
risk for disease
can and cannot be corrected by a
particular drugs mechanism
we have the potential to improve success
of our clinical trials
and while clearly some interventions
a targeted approach to prevention and
therapy are not necessarily warranted
the repercussions of a lifetime devoted
to ineffective prevention efforts or
side effects
drug without therapeutic benefit cannot
be understated
so before we go any further i'd like to
take to take a moment
now to briefly go over what exactly a
polygenic risk score is
and how it is calculated so that we're
all on the same page
a poly risk score or a genome-wide score
is a single composite number based on
the variation
at multiple positions in the genome
it has many uses historically it's been
used
as the best prediction for a trait or
disease is
consider multiple genetic variants all
at once
so how exactly do we determine this
single composite number
so first we obtain a cohort of people
both with and without a particular
disease
it cannot be overstated but this step of
establishing cases and controls
is probably the most crucial step as
having poorly defined phenotypes can
lead to absent or meaningless results
then we test each common genetic variant
to see whether it is associated with the
disease
the results of this type of
investigation known as a genome-wide
association study
are often visualized using a manhattan
plot which is shown here with the
chromosomes along the x-axis and the
significance level of each variant
on the y-axis we can also report the
results
of in we can also report these results
in a simple
table where each row is
the second column shows how one allele
called the effect allele is associated
with the disease
and the alternate allele is not
associated with the disease
the fourth column labeled odds ratio
reports the odds of having the disease
if an individual
has the effect allele so if we are
considering just the first row for now
that would be the a allele over the odds
of having the disease if an inch
ultimate alternate or the g allele
and the last column is the significance
of this effect
typically calculated with either a
chi-square test or a closely related
statistic
for the results of this table are known
as the gwa summary statistics
getting these gloss summary statistics
from a large g
getting these gy summary statistics is
the first step in generating a polygenic
risk score
this original cohort of cases and
controls is called
discovery sample because we are well
discovering
which variants are associated with the
disease
in the second step we get another cohort
known as the target sample
from another non-overlapping population
that has also been
genotyped we established the variance in
common between the discovery and target
sample
making sure to eliminate variants that
we that are physically very close to one
another on the chromosomes
if we if we were to keep all of the
variants that are physically very close
to one another on the chromosomes
rather than keeping say one variant to
represent a particular region
we may end up inflating a or importance
assigned to these chromosome regions
essentially counting the same region
multiple times when it really should
only be counted once
that each person in the target sample we
calculate the polygenic risk score
and we do this by multiplying the odds
ratio ratio from this
discovery gus by the number of effect
alleles that
that particular individual possesses
this
procter represents an individual's risk
for the disease that is attributed
to the alleles at this specific variant
these individual scores can then be
averaged across the genome to form an
overall polygenic risk score for each
person
so essentially we have calculated a
weighted average
and that's it
so circling back to the original premise
it might seem obvious enough that we
should simply generate a bunch of these
polygenic risk scores for each of the
diseases we plan to evaluate
patients however in tackling this
problem
of combining clinical risk factors and
polygenic risk in real patients
seemed to me a disconnect more
specifically
my greatest concern regarding using
polygenic risk scores for evaluating
evaluating risk for common diseases in
real patients
was that we were actually just measuring
at least in part
some of the same genetic risk i looked
at
use cases for polygenic risk scores from
one of the studies i mentioned earlier
which included type 2 diabetes coronary
artery disease
atrial fibrillation inflammatory bowel
disease and breast cancer
and thought
these common diseases share many of the
same quantifiable risk factors
that is diet induced obesity tobacco use
and alcohol use
and aren't these modifiable risk factors
also partially genetic
is there any evidence that the genetic
variants underlying these modifiable
risk factors
could in fact be the same
now if they were the same it would make
sense that individuals who had one
modifiable risk factor
would be have a set modifiable risk
factor
right so i first thought it would be a
good idea to look at the epidemiology
literature for the co-occurrence of both
obesity and substance use
nailing down these numbers however is
notoriously tricky
for a number of reasons these modifiable
risk factors or lifestyle measures
have complex and often time dependent
relationships with each other
however some important ones to note here
are
alcohol contains seven calories per gram
with inconsistent effects on food intake
the nicotine found in tobacco suppresses
appetite and decreases food intake
public environments where alcohol is
readily available
cigarettes are also more likely to be
present
and commercially available food stuffs
high in fat
are also more likely to be high in sugar
i will share with you published by the
u.s
national comorbidity survey which
reported that a current substance use
disorder
which includes alcohol or any
recreational drug
is not statistically more or less common
in a person with
obesity defined here as a body mass
index over 30.
happiness or afterwards about the
epidemiology
of particular combinations of food and
drugs
but from my review of the literature
obesity and substance use of any kind
do not co-occur in individuals more
frequently than we'd be
expected by chance despite this
there is a substantial amount of
literature
that supports a common biological basis
for obesity and substance use disorders
reasoning that food and drugs compete
for overlapping reward mechanisms
which hinder coincidence of both
conditions in a given person
intuitively appealing explanation for
the lack of epidemiological studies
reporting
morbidity it is also very hard to test
in people
for all the reasons i just mentioned but
before we get into that
let's take a brief look at the types of
evidence for a unified reward system
that is responsive to both food
intake and drug use
so here i have summarized three types of
evidence for shared biology between
nutrient intake and drug use in humans
the first type of evidence is from human
population genetic studies
so recent genome-wide association
studies for macronutrient intake and
alcohol consumption
report genome-wide significant variants
in the
fjf21 beta-clotho pathway
which function in non-humane primate
models as a ligand receptor pair
and nutrient sensor that controls
overall food intake
the type of evidence from energy studies
tomography studies of binge eating
disorder obesity
alcohol use disorder and cocaine use
disorder
all report loss of new opioid and
dopamine g2 receptors
in cortical subcortical and striatal
brain regions
the third type of evidence from lesion
studies which report associations
between damaged
specific regions of the frontal temporal
lobes
weight change and disruption of smoking
addiction
while in isolation none of these studies
are particularly definitive
together with insights from animal
models they justify a more systematic
evaluation
of the impact of common genetic
variation on both nutrient
intake and drug use in humans
so all for this led to the sensation
in my dissertation research which was
can we
leverage any genetic share between
modifiable risk factors
to improve prediction of obesity and
substance use disorders
so to answer this question i will walk
you through my approach
so first i aggregated multiple reward
system phenotypes together
second i identify genome-wide variants
associated with this aggregate phenotype
third i constructed a reward system
polygenic risk score
to predict individuals with obesity and
substance addiction
and lastly i compared the sensitivity
and specificity of the reward system
polygenic risk score
to an obesity and a substance addiction
polygenic risk score respectively
so before i can show you the results of
my approach however
we must first talk about the study
participants who made this investigation
possible in the first place
so for this work i used the health
information donated by people who
participated in the uk biobank project
which is a population-based cohort study
of over 500 000 people
aged 40 to 69 when they were recruited
between 2006 and 2010.
all of these people were living in the
united kingdom when enrolled
and were assessed at one of 22 centers
that were contributed throughout the
country and intended to target
a diverse set of participants from both
urban and rural communities
of various socioeconomic backgrounds
each participant answered a series of
surveys and provided researchers with a
number of physical measures including
height and weight
or multiple visits
from this initial cohort i identified a
sub-sample of participants from my study
that met
my criteria specifically i
included uk participants if they were of
white british ancestry
they had their height and weight
measured they reported their substance
addiction status
and they completed at least one diet
survey
this left me with just over 80 000 uk
biobank participants who met the
eligibility criteria for inclusion
okay now that we have our study
participants i want to clarify the
outcome measures that
just for specifically
anyone with a body mass index greater
than or equal to 30 kgs per meter
squared
was designated as having obesity in
addition
a person was designated as having a
substance addiction
they reported yes to the question
are you or have you ever been addicted
to alcohol
illicit or recreational drugs or
prescription or over-the-counter
medications
a person was also designated as having a
substance addiction
if they were greater than or equal 10
years of cigarette smoking so
clearly these definitions are coarse and
imperfect representations of obesity and
substance addiction
and future work will most assuredly
explore the extreme heterogeneity
among people with various forms of
obesity and substance addiction
these definitions were chosen as a
suitable first pass
the simplicity and the maximal
participant inclusion in mind
so once i had compiled the data set
comprising my study subsample from the
full uk
outbank cohort i split the data into
three groups
seventy percent of the participants were
assigned randomly to the training set
and fifteen percent each to the
validation and test sets
i use the training for my genome-wide
association study
discover variants associated with a
reward system
aggregate phenotype i then use
participants in the validation set
as my target sample to construct account
polygenic risk scores for this project
i calculated 16 polygenic risk scores
using
them called the clumping and
thresholding algorithm during the
initial or so-called clumping phase of
this algorithm
we select the most significant variant
iteratively
by first computing the correlation
between this index variant
and nearby variance within some genetic
distance
for instance here i used 250 kilobases
we then remove all nearby variants that
are correlated with this index variant
below some r squared value
and we repeat this procedure until all
the variants have been considered
then during the second or three phase of
the algorithm
full variance larger than some
significance level or p-value
for this project i chose to test a range
of r squared values between 0.2 and 0.8
and p values between 0.5 and 5 times 10
to the negative 8.
the best performing polygenic risk score
from the validation set
was then used obesity and substance
addiction
in the test lab
so what do the participants in this
study actually look like
i want to draw your attention here to
the column titled
sub sample the participants in this
study
were about 57 years old on average
54 were women 22
were obese that is had a bmi greater
than or equal to 30
and the 54 and 45 had a history
of or a current addiction to a substance
according to my earlier definition
what i also would like appreciate is
that the makeup of the training
validation and test sets
are approximately the makeup of the
entire study subsample
which you can see by looking across the
columns by each of the participant
characteristics listed
likewise the makeup of the sub sample is
approximately equivalent to the full uk
volume cohort
where there were data available this
assessment assures us that any findings
uncovered here
are more likely to be generalizable
despite the non-random sampling i used
to generate our study cohort
i want to take also the point out that
there was not an even distribution
of use across the different drugs
included in this study
so in this figure i showed a venn
diagram of
all the participants in the training set
as you can see
then the of the nearly 26 000 people
designated as having a substance
addiction about 25 000 of these
participants were designated as such
due to a history of 10 or more pack
years of smoking
as shown in the far right in purple
rather than say a history of addiction
to alcohol
the other drug shown in the remaining
bubbles
this is important to keep in mind
especially when we evaluate later the
predictive ability of loci associated
with a reward system average phenotype
now that you have a sense for the
participants included in this study
how did i actually aggregate multiple
reward phenotypes together
so to accomplish this i decided to treat
addictive nutrients and drugs
as pharmalogical agents that produce an
effect on an individual's reward system
could be used to estimate the just
required the steady-state
pharmacokinetics for that individual
set another assumes that
for example if a person smokes 20
cigarettes per day
they do so because it is required to
achieve the same effect as someone else
who smokes only one cigarette a day
now take this opportunity to point out
this assumption and overlooks the role
of alternative mechanisms for
differences in nutrient and drug intake
across humans
such as variation in a drug's rate of
onset rather than the pk steady state
dose
while disentangling this complexity is
an important avenue
of future work i decided to move forward
with this assumption
at least for this initial study
it follows then that the corollary to
the assumption
is that the relative daily intakes
across a population
reflect the variation in the reward
system's response to a specific nutrient
or drug
i then constructed
measures of nutrient intake and drug use
after an extensive literature review i
along with the guidance of my advisors
included percent energy from fat and
sugar
as well as caffeine alcohol and
cigarettes per day
for inclusion in the set of reward
system phenotypes
it should also be noted here that these
cartoon drawings are idealized versions
of these distributions and that while
some of these nutrients and drugs
specifically percent energy from fat and
percent energy from sugar
were approximately normally distributed
the drug use
distributions were not as such i
performed transform
transformations of these data in line
with theory and our a priori knowledge
of the
data generating process underlying these
distributions
when it came to actually combining these
nutrients and drugs
i decided to model a reward system
aggregate phenotype in two
different ways the first was an
additive model where all substances
together
achieve the steady-state pharmacokinetic
effect
this was calculated for each individual
by taking the sum
across the set of nutrients and drugs
the second method i used was a single
agent model
where one substance is sufficient to
achieve the steady state
pharmacokinetic effect while the others
have negligible effects
this was calculated for each individual
by taking the maximum value
across the set of nutrients and drugs
and then conducted gmos to identify any
low side
were associated with these two scores
this is the manhattan plot of the the
results of this study
again the chromosome position is plotted
along the x-axis and a measure of
statistical significance is applauded
along the y-axis
from my analysis i found four loci that
surpassed my preset significance level
and
and variants at these four loci are
highlighted in orange
associated with the maximum reward
system phenotype score are
known as triangles while the locus
significantly associated with the sun
reward system aggregate phenotype score
is shown as a square today i'm going to
elaborate on
two of these loci
the first one i want to high is
chromosome 15.
this variant is a previously identified
eqtl
for a gene located only eight kilobases
upstream called
sip1a1 this gene code for one of the
cytochrome p450 enzymes
responsible for both xenobiotic drug
metabolism
and metabolism of polyunsaturated fatty
acids
in addition sip1a1 activity is induced
by polycyclic aromatic hydrocarbons
which are found in cigarette smoke
these results similar to gwas of single
use like alcohol and nicotine
demonstrate the key
drug metabolism in conferring disease
susceptibility to reward related
behaviors
the second locus i discuss is on
chromosome 17.
this variant is only 15 kilobases
away from the gene that codes for
neuropeptide b
interestingly we know that neuropeptide
acts in the brain through two g protein
coupled receptors to regulate energy
homeostasis
as well as hyper algae in response to
inflammatory pain
here showing the weight trajectory of
male mpd receptor knockout mice on both
a regular
panel and on a high diet on the right
as you can see mpd receptor knockout
mice
demonstrate adult onset obesity and that
effect is exacerbated in the presence of
a high fat diet
these results are intriguing and a
closer look at this look at
its potential role in genetic
susceptibility to obesity and substance
addiction in humans is probably
warranted
one interesting follow-up study of this
work could include
fine mapping of the genetic variation in
npd
specifically using the uk biobank
participants whole egg zone data
which as i understand it is slated for
release later this year
next i've used g results to construct a
reward system
polygenic risk score to predict
individuals with
obesity and substance addiction i then
compared the sensitivity and specificity
of the reward system polygenic score to
an obesity
and a substance addiction polygenic risk
score respectively
so first on the left i plotted a
receiver operating characteristic curve
comparing these two
rewards polygenic risk scores shown
in yellow and green to predict obesity
as compared to an obesity polygenic risk
or shown in red
and two null or background control
polygenic risk scores in
blue and purple so to be clear
the two male phenotype scores were
calculated by aggregating five randomly
chosen phenotypes together
sampled from the list of data fields
requested in our uk
bank application these were included in
the analysis
to make sure that any increase in
predictive ability from our
polygynic risk scores could not be
attributed to the inclusion of an
aggregate phenotype polygenic risk or
regardless of what those phenotypes
actually were
to point out that in addition to each
participant's genetic risk for disease
all of these polygenic risk score models
include two
important environmental exposures as
predictors
specifically they include a measure of
the rate of poverty in the neighborhood
where the participant was living
when they were recruited into the study
as well as whether the participant
reported being physically or sexually
abused as a child
i included these environmental ex
because they are repeatedly cited in the
literature
strongly correlated with both outcomes
and can
somewhat reasonably be ascertained at a
clinic visit
fortunately despite the seemingly
pertinent gwas hits i showed previously
the reward system polygenic risk scores
were not able to improve the prediction
of obesity above and beyond that of an
obesity polygenic risk score
likewise as seen on the right i did not
find
evidence that a reward system polygenic
risk score could improve prediction of
substance addiction beyond a substance
addiction specific polygenic risk score
all together with these results i
unfortunately cannot provide any new
evidence
either for or against the hypothesis
that the biology
underlying nutrient intake and drug use
in humans is shared
but rather i can highlight that these
results suggest
that simple measures of obesity and
substance addiction
capturing lifetime genetic risk rather
than genetic risk at specific
developmental periods
such as across a childhood adolescence
or middle age
are unlikely to provide the complexity
needed to make
useful clinical predictions going
forward
even as sample sizes and the number of
genotyped
variants grow so to increase our
understanding of the relationship
between obesity and substance addiction
at the population level
as a means to better advise patients
regarding their risk
following the same people over time will
be crucial
while thinking about pre well the
thinking around predisposition
to common and complex diseases is co is
present
is usually presented as either more or
less
genetically mediated this work suggests
that the degree to which genetics is
involved
may not be the only important factor but
rather pinpointing pinpointing when
during the lifespan
a specific genetic susceptibility
actually manifests
may prove equally as important
so while the complexity inherent to this
problem of
biology underlying nutrients and drug
use in humans
may seem daunting careful longitudinal
study design that takes into account
both an individual's genetics
and environmental exposures over time
are on the horizon
and from a clinical perspective
disentangling this complexity
again is crucial if a young child is at
high risk for obesity but that risk is
only likely to occur in adulthood
embarking on a burdensome dietary
regimen or clinical monitoring during
their early years
is going to be a source of distress with
little appreciable benefit
now before i conclude i will put my
results in context
especially with regard to polygenic risk
scores for obesity or bmi
which has achieved some recent successes
so despite the lackluster performance of
my reward system polygenic risk score
for predicting obesity
work by another leading group in this
area
nicely demonstrated with their polygenic
risk score for extreme obesity
how complicated the picture of polygenic
risk for this disease
really is when considered over the
lifespan
here i am showing you a figure from
their paper on the incidence of severe
obesity
defined as a bmi over 40 plotted over
years of follow-up despite that there is
a 30-pound difference in weight between
people whose
polygenic risk score is in the top 10
versus the bottom 10
and that this difference in weight is
essentially the same
in adolescents and middle-aged adults
the authors show that their polygenic
risk score can still predict a
significant
proportion of young adults with a bmi in
the normal range who eventually go on to
become
obese these results provide evidence
that even with a highly predictive
polygenic risk
or further gains are likely to be found
by phenotyping not only
middle aged or older adults but also
kiddos
thankfully this approach is in direct
alignment with growing efforts in the
area of early detection of disease and
are the logical next step
to ultimately slow disease progression
so i've listed here some of the major
study
limitations of this study the first
which i've discussed a bit already
is that only simple measures of obesity
that is body mass index
body mass index and substance addiction
that capture
lifetime risk were considered
also study was based on a
biased sample of the human population
specifically it only included people of
white british ancestry
in addition most phenotypes in this
study were based on surveys
rather direct measurement
i want to take a moment to expand on
this last limitation
as i uncovered a few challenges with
regard to sampling participants for
inclusion in the study
so in future accounting for these
sources of bias will be critical to
success of similar population-based
studies on the shared biology of
nutrient intake and drug use in humans
so specifically this table shows the
proportion of participants with obesity
and substance addiction
by the number of diet surveys they
completed
if you look across the first row under
the heading
uk bio bank i hope you can see the
stepwise decrease in the number of
participants with
obesity and substance addiction as the
number of diet surveys completed grows
while this effect was curiosity
the effect for substance addiction was
substantial
with the rate of substance addiction
among people who
didn't complete any diet surveys at
nearly 80 percent
but only 40 among people who completed
two or more surveys
furthermore missing data on physical or
sexual
abuse as a child was merely
deterministic for substance addiction
so of the participants in the training
set who either
did not report their history of a
history of physical or sexual abuse as a
child
98 had a history of substance addiction
this is in stark contrast to the
proportion of people with a substance
addiction
who reported either yes or no that they
experienced abuse as a child
conclusion my intent here today was to
demonstrate
that every phenotype approach can
provide useful
insights into the biology of common
diseases
and that longitudinal measures of
obesity and substance addiction that
capture genetic risk
across the lifespan will likely be
required to make
our clinical predictions more useful to
patients
future directions of this work i am
interested in the following questions
do the reward system aggregate phenotype
associated loci replicate in people of
other ancestries two can the reward
system polygenic risk score
improve prediction of abdominal obesity
for example waist to hip ratio
and then third can the reward system
polygenic risk score
predict obesity and substance addiction
in adolescents or young adults
now before i take questions i need to
take
uh more than a few minutes to recognize
the substantial amount of work that was
done on this project
by many many other people besides me
so first i want to thank
the amazing members of my dissertation
committee
who without their guidance not that this
work would have
even been remotely possible so
specifically i want to thank
juan ming um who's the chair of my
committee
joanna hansen and dan marks
so for all of you graduate students in
the audience currently looking for
advisors this is my ringing endorsement
of their mentorship and guidance
i want to thank the faculty members both
those
in demise and from other departments at
ohsu who have provided
to this work one point or another during
my journey
to becoming a scientist so specifically
i'd like to thank lucia cabote
alice boudreau suzanne mitchell michael
mooney
jessica minier beth wilmot reid thompson
dion chase david kohler and ken
thornberg
of course i also need to thank all the
dmi students posts
and clinical fellows that over five
years as a student in this department
have offered words of encouragement and
challenged me
to be the best scientific colleague
possible um and i'm sure that i've
missed some of you
in the photos here but please know your
creativity and commitment to the pursuit
of knowledge
never ceases to amaze me and i
especially want to take this moment
to thank aurora blucher who is wise
beyond for years and was the best
student mentor a graduate student could
ask for
i want to thank all the demise faculty
and staff
for providing such a rich scientific
community and the support necessary to
accomplish
all of the work i've presented here
today i especially like to thank bill
hirsch for always sending me just the
right book or
paper to read
i want to program
students and staff it's very unclear to
me
what i will do to keep myself centered
now that i do not have all of you to
provide my weekly wednesday dose of md
phd journal club
i'm probably still operating under the
assumption i will just keep showing up
indefinitely
and i must thank dave jacoby who
repeatedly and enthusiastically
supported me when i said i wanted to
pursue
bioinformatics for my phd thank you
also for your uncanny ability to always
say just the thing that i need to hear
my family friends especially to my mom
and dad
never cease to encourage me to show up
every day and do the very best work
possible and now for my last two thank
yous
i have to admit i'm actually really
grateful that i'm not sitting up
in front of all of you because it is
unclear whether i would be able to hold
it together
[ __ ] mentor
thank you since the day i walked into
your office and hatfield for the first
time back in 2014
and you wrote out on your whiteboard all
the things that i was to learn
as a student in your program in the
program you did not fail to deliver
on a single one and while i'm pretty
excited about the prospect of receiving
my phd after all these years
i have to say that i'm even more excited
for an opportunity
to give another student an experience
that even remotely resembles my time
with you
and last of all my husband reed
thank you please know that if i could
get away with putting your name on all
the work i presented here today
i would and
now i would love to take your questions
thank you
great thank thank you kristen um i have
a
question for you um and um
it may not be possible um with the data
in the uk biobank but
um given the um you know there's
a lot of emphasis these days on social
determinants of health
particularly capturing social
determinants of health
in the electronic health record and
other data sets
would would you think that is such data
available
may it add more precision to your model
um yes so that's a great question
so um specifically in terms of the
aspect of your question with regards to
what is in what else is available
in um the uk biobank data set so
i chose the child trauma for its
simplicity
but actually the two questions that i
used to generate
um that variable were taken from a
childhood trauma screener
um they're the five question version
which is which is what was
included in the uk biobank additionally
um the the rate of poverty in the region
where the participants live
um what is which is referred to
which you can look it's called the
townsend deprivation index
um then it's also a composite score
similar to the one i was attempting to
um uh to uh
to present here today and it's a
combination
of multiple factors including um
rooms in the house car ownership
home ownership employment status
and all of those individual level data
are actually available from most
participants in the uk biobank
um and uh and could be used
to build a perhaps more complicated
model but
one that is potentially much more
predictive
does that answer your question yeah yeah
great
yeah other questions for kristin either
uh you can ask them verbally or type
them in the chat box
trying to see if anyone already asked
any questions but please do speak
up it's much easier for me to hear you
um over
than to read your question
i have one this is shannon um great job
by the way uh
so if you were advising someone who was
you
um knowing everything you know now about
this idea
of these biologically based kind of
aggregate
scores yeah what would be what would be
kind of
the advice that you would give right so
you now have the
the hindsight so let's say you're
mentoring a student um
you've experienced everything you know
everything you know about the data now
what would be your kind of top
suggestions to them if basically they
were looking at two
other phenotypes that they felt were
biologically potentially related in
terms of a circuit yeah
it made sense uh and wanted to use let's
say the same
let's keep it easier for you wanted to
use the same resource which is the uk
bio bank just in terms of
um strategies and maybe also you know
ways to get around some limitations
potentially
what would your advice be i think i
i mean so in in proposing and completing
this project
i was really hoping to get two things
out of
the full experience which were to
learn something about the biology
underlying uh nutrient intake and drug
use in humans and then also to
potentially improve prediction make it
clinically useful
and you know trying to do both of those
things
at the same time is very difficult
um as bill sort of already pointed out
um there are a lot make
formula building more complicated models
also have all
often has the benefit of um being more
predictive
and alternatively though we don't always
have the
means or methods to actually disentangle
why it's more predictive and from a
clinical application
standpoint um the reset
actually and and potentially having
um clinicians use these predictive
models
um there's some uh you know
reluctance perhaps and so i think what i
would
the advice that i would um give a
student would just be think
really um take some time to think about
like what really are their goals
in pursuing a particular project
regarding sort of that dichotomy um
is there is really their goal in
pursuing a question around a shared
circuit
um are they really interested in sort of
a greater understanding of the biology
or is their primary motivation um
working with clinicians and
trying to provide something that could
be really useful in the clinic
and like i said it's not it's sort of a
false dichotomy like
i tried to do both and there's no like
inherent reason that i'm aware of why
like
it it's not possible that this could
have worked
but it is very it is difficult and that
um being really thoughtful about the
motivation behind
the problem they're they're hoping to
investigate
is is something that um i cannot
understate
great thank you
anyone else have any questions about
methods or
other things i found hi kristen yes
sam i just sort of had a very general
question about thinking um as a
physician
as a future physician what sort of
messages would you take away from what
you've learned in this dissertation what
sort of things do you think
you'd like to see talk to your physician
colleagues about this area
yeah yeah no um very good question
um so i think um i don't know i'm sort
of of the of the bent
of like just wanting to share like the
exciting parts of the data
um and so i think um you know
like at the end of my presentation but
especially regarding
sort of these like sampling issues and
specifically with respect to the child
abuse exposures
um i i think that that was a really
that was like an un unintended finding
um of this work
and i think um is
needs to be validated obviously in in
other
and other data before presented as true
anywhere near
uh truth but i think that bringing those
type of data forward
um and presenting them to my physician
colleagues
um can really sort of um provide context
to um these behaviors that are
common um but that are also really
really hard to treat
um and to um and to really move forward
with patients in a way that
meaningfully improves their health
lovely thank you
any other questions hi
uh christine this is uh shawan how are
you good how are you thanks for coming
thank you
uh i have a comment and as you know that
we our group is also
working with justice commoner and others
we're also working on protogenic risk
factors
risk scores and i think prs is indeed
making its way into the clinical arena
so let me just give you sort of a few
scenarios number one is if you get your
brc
and testing down by let's say embry
genetics or
by uh myriar that's the leading
vendor in the field you you will not
only get brca1 and testing result but
you also get your polygenic risk score
for your breast cancer so the
information has been out and you will
get that information
so if you have brca1 and 2 negative then
you'll get your score prs score
and that will predict your risk for
breast cancer development
now how are you going to use that
information we don't know that yet
but that's been addressed in large
clinical trials
i think one of which is the wisdom trial
the other one is
my p-e-b-s my personal breast cancer
screening trial in europe
they are based on clinical factor
polygenic risk or mammographic density
and as you indicated some small
fractional patient might actually have
very high
risk for breast cancer even higher than
the a single
monogenic gene carrier and those
patients might need to be screened more
extensively
so those are actually making into a
clinical arena and i think
you are your studies on the forefront of
that that will help us understand
persons individuals the cancer risk and
i think that could be very helpful
and i think that's just cancer because
i'm oncology so forgive me for being
never minded but i do think this is very
important work so it's a very nice
presentation thank you
yeah no thank you so much for that
comment and i think it's really
important to
cancer is a really exciting realm
for the application of this work um
specifically
in terms of mapping um
risk with interventions which for um
it's not obvious already like the
interventions
for obesity and substance use disorders
um are not always quite as clear
and and so um just in the context of
cancer and using these polygenic risk
scores and other genetic scores
mapped to then particular treatment
avenues
is a very exciting and interesting
place to do work especially because of
that sort of like
one-two step between um uh
testing and diagnostics and mapping that
to
um actual interventions um that are
sort of in line with that diagnostic um
and there's
like wonderful modeling work um being
done
in that area um obviously i give a shout
out to
my mentor and also to my um
my uh graduate student mentor who's now
post doc um here at ohsu aurora blucher
it's very uh very exciting and very
interesting to actually do that type of
modeling
um for real patients
hi kristin this is joanna hi joanna
hi so great job that was a really
wonderful presentation
and um i'm just curious kind of again
thinking about
your future role as a clinician
what do you think is the age at which
information about a polygenic risk or
would be
most useful especially in the context of
something like obesity
and part of the reason i bring this up
many of these cohort studies are
conducted in older adult populations but
i know we've talked a little bit about
whether that's really the best
population so just give me your thoughts
on when you think this information might
actually be most useful
so first this is this is a wonderful
question and
i think that you've really touched on
the fact that it
we we don't really know because most of
the
to actually generate most of the
polygenic risk scores for obesity and
bmi
have all been conducted well not all but
many most
um especially ones that have had the
power to
to actually be be predictive
um are have been conducted in
middle-aged adults or older adults
and as like my presentation and my work
here today has sort of
uh extended that you know this is really
something that you know knowing exactly
when genetic susceptibility manifests is
something that
we just don't use to say at this point
that said i think your question also
brings up an important point about
the idea of what do we really gain
by um actually communicating genetic
risks to patients
um is is a person who is informed or
about their genetic risk or in the
scenario that you're talking about
for in in the pediatric scenario the
parent
um is that actually going to be
translate to
like useful prevention efforts and i
think that's an
open question um there has been some
very nice work and
the name of the study is and the authors
of that study are escaping me at this
moment
but i can definitely get that for you um
and the study that i'm referring to
actually like
the the actual like you know
efforts that a patient can actually
embark on
in response to learning about their
genetic risk
is is not always shown to be of uh
immediate clinical benefit and so really
disentangling like
how how patients in general um
you know absorb and potentially use
genetic risk
for um for their own life in their own
decision making
in terms of you know what what uh actual
um changes they decide to make or
interventions for
their kiddos um i think remains to be
determined
um but is probably the one of the most
important parts of implementing these
polygenic risk scores for common complex
diseases
and is a really really important area
for future work
thanks
okay well maybe um at this point i will
uh will turn your turn you over to your
committee
they may have some further questioning
so those of us who are not
on kristen's exam committee can leave
the webex room and then the committee
will
talk with her further great job kristin